there is concern the coming months could
create a twin endemic covet is
continuing to search unfortunately
doctors are now warning the flu will
also be a major threat over the next few
months when flu does come back and it
will come back it's going to come back
very aggressively health experts are
warning that this year's flu season
could be much worse than last year's the
cdc says from 9 million to 45 million
people in the u.s get infected with the
flu annually leading to 12 000 to 61 000
deaths but that wasn't the case last
year last year's flu season was nearly
non-existent public health and clinical
laboratories reported only a few
thousand cases of the flu for the season
and the coveted pandemic is a big reason
why those numbers were so low wsj
reporter felicia schwartz has been
reporting on the upcoming flu season all
of the experts and virologists that i
spoke to
in the course of reporting all this out
said that there will definitely be more
flu than last year
and it could potentially be an earlier
and more severe season just as a result
of kind of the weird dynamics last
year flu virus can spread to other
people through exposure mainly from
droplets made when people who have the
flu cough sneeze or talk less often a
person might get the flu from contact
with surfaces that have flu virus on it
and since the start of the pandemic
health experts have found covet 19
spreads in much the same way during last
year's flu season with the rollout of
covid 19 vaccines just getting started
much of the u.s was in lockdown social
distancing guidelines were in effect and
many people were masked all things that
helped prevent the spread of covid and
also help prevent the flu now covet
vaccines are widely available and people
are interacting more people are
back at school back at work to some
extent depending on where you live in
the u.s there are or aren't
social distancing restrictions like mask
wearing and you know congregating in
large groups and so on and so there is a
lot more opportunity for the flu to
spread this year as a population there's
also less immunity to the flu this year
population immunity occurs when people
are naturally infected by the virus or
have received a vaccine since so few
people were infected with the flu last
year because of social distancing people
haven't been able to build up their
natural immune defenses this lack of
immunity could contribute to what some
health experts are calling a twindemoc
it refers to the threat of a severe flu
outbreak on top of the covet 19 pandemic
which could be detrimental to the health
care system
i think the fear
from health authorities is that
hospitals can be further overwhelmed one
hospital administrator was telling me
maybe they'd have to cut back on clinic
hours or reschedule other procedures if
they're having to make these kinds of
choices they might have to scale some
things back
this overlap could also cause confusion
among people about whether they have
covet 19 or the flu because they have
similar symptoms it could be hard to
diagnose which condition people have
based on the symptoms alone the main
difference between the two is that
coveted symptoms typically appear about
five days after infection but symptoms
can appear two to fourteen days after
infection and flu symptoms usually
appear about one to four days after
infection
the good news is the best ways to
prevent catching the flu are the ones
many people are already familiar with
infectious disease experts and
epidemiologists really urge you to get a
flu shot on top of that hand washing
good hygiene if you're already wearing
masks and practicing social distancing
for corona that definitely can't hurt
you if you're looking to avoid catching
the flu the flu season commonly strikes
the u.s october through may with cases
peaking in december through february so
the cdc recommends getting a flu shot
every year by the end of october to get
ahead of it
[Music]
the cdc says you can get both the flu
shot and the coveted vaccine including
boosters at the same time which wasn't
the guidance last year the shots were so
new they didn't really have enough
information to make that recommendation
but now they're saying yes you can go
get those two shots at the same time so
depending also on the booster campaign
maybe there will be some more
co-administration of shots
as far as side effects from taking both
the coveted vaccine and the flu shot at
the same time the cdc says the side
effects people experience are similar to
what they experience when the vaccines
are given separately some pharmaceutical
companies are even working on a combined
flu shot and coveted vaccine that could
be administered in the same jab but
there's no clear timeline yet on when
those would be available while experts
believe this flu season could strike
earlier and more severely than usual
there's still no guarantee it will be
one person i interviewed described to me
as a tricky devil
it's very hard to predict so i think
there is a general feeling that it will
be worse and some people think it could
be very bad but it's kind of hard to
know at this point if you're worried
about the flu probably the single best
thing you could do is go out and take a
shot
you